so we made it we finally made it to the
end of the republican national
convention
i was talking yesterday on the bonus
show with pat and just with people in my
personal life that
i can remember no political event like
the 2020 republican national convention
which so exhausted me from politics in
general because it was
so disgusting and so depraved
so lie riddled that it's an
impossibility to even
keep up with the amount of dishonesty
and lies
and yesterday it was all capped off by
donald trump's speech officially
accepting the nomination he did it at
the white house
with 1500 people in an audience no masks
barely a mask no testing in the middle
of a pandemic
completely irresponsible in every way
the imagery
included sirens in the entire background
as a soundtrack to the speech because of
massive protests that broke out outside
of the white house
and as you can see if you look at the
picture
of this crowd at the white house it
doesn't look like the type of speech
that would be given accepting a
nomination during a pandemic
questions about whether it's even legal
to do this at the white house using the
white house as a political
prop and of course the um prudence
of using the uh uh such or having such a
large crowd during a pandemic
certainly questionable at best now the
entire thing
was a fascistic nightmare with donald
trump continuing to paint
uh the left as socialist marxist
agitators if you've taken a look at joe
biden's policy platform or the last 30
years of joe biden's
public policy positions there is uh
really nothing that could be described
as socialistic
or marxist in any way but this is the
way that they are framing it
trump going on for 70 minutes starting
to have
sort of the feeling of these
never-ending fidel castro speeches
those would go on for hours this only
felt like ours
and donald trump's orange face starting
to melt during the event and i said
yesterday you know melania's accent is
really beneath us
donald trump's physical appearance is
part of his narcissistic delusional
complex i think it is very much on this
side of the line and it's
part of what trump imagines as the idea
of trump
that people want the idea that people
need to see him in this particular way
this bizarre
shade of orange i don't know if we call
it ochre what we call it
uh this 70-minute droning speech and
what's interesting as we get into the
clips is you might realize that he's
speaking so slowly that even though the
speech was long time wise
it's very low on actual content because
the
words per minute are extremely low it is
the type of speech that you would do
if you have these uh sort of
authoritarian tendencies of wanting the
crowd to see you as
this great savior but yet not really
having very much to say
uh let's start donald trump actually
sort of rubbing the noses of the
audience
into the fact that he's using the white
house as a political prop take a look
this november we must turn the page
forever on this failed
political class the fact is i'm here
what's the name of that building
but i'll say it differently the fact is
we're here
and they're not
so as i mentioned before uh are arguably
against the law to use the white house
for a political speech like this there
aren't going to be repercussions
i don't even know how much time we
should spend uh wasting uh
we should waste on that because it will
be a waste the opportunity is removing
trump in november he's not going to have
any consequences for using the white
house
in this way then donald trump really
just not making sense throughout the
70-minute speech
uh becoming even more and more orange
his face looking like it was sort of
melting kind of like the joker in the
the 1989 batman film um and
making less and less sense in terms of
his speech here is trump saying that he
has pioneered the fatality rate on the
virus
thanks to advances we have pioneered the
fatality rate and you look at it and you
look at the numbers
really unclear what that means and then
also really unclear but far
scarier trump talking about putting
so-called patriotic education back in
schools
as i drop my sharpie take a listen take
a listen to this already under
construction we will fully restore
patriotic education to our schools and
always protect
we will always always protect free
speech on college campuses
so that actually made the crowd
momentarily seem alive
in the middle of these endless monotones
but that's really scary
patriotic education back in schools if
you've got a republican telling you
they're going to make education
patriotic
you're right to be scared and concerned
trump continuing this very strange
monotonous delivery here is another
section of it it's not clear
trump believes what he's saying it's not
clear trump even understands what he's
saying
but he is saying it in the strange
monotone
and sparked a new age of scientific
discovery
we set the trends in art and music radio
and film
sport and literature and we did it all
with style and confidence and flair
because that is who we are
whenever our way of life was threatened
our heroes
answered the call from yorktown
to gettysburg from normandy to
iwo jima i mean the delivery couldn't
possibly be less inspiring so in
addition to the duration which was far
too long reminding me of fidel castro
the complete lack of of energy
in terms of communicating belief
also reminding me of of just other
authoritarians who just drone on
and on and on at one point
aaron rupar pointed out on twitter the
delivery
almost sounds like gregorian chanting
it's a very unusual way to deliver a
speech take a look
and america against all threats and
protect america
against all dangers we will lead america
into new frontiers of ambition and when
someone speaks in this way
there's no way to discern a narrative
there's no way to sort of craft an
arc and in fact when the cameras would
pan to the crowd
people were on their phones people were
talking to each other a couple of people
looked like they were sleeping because
this is not how you deliver a speech and
tell a story
whether it's a good story or not whether
it's an honest story or not that's a dif
this is just not how you engage a crowd
then
again donald trump citing veterans
choice
as an accomplishment remember veterans
choice was signed into law by barack
obama in 2014
we also passed va accountability and va
choice our great veterans were taking
care of our veterans
this actually is something many speakers
have been doing
ivanka trump who introduced the
president yesterday
also touted veterans choices and
accomplishment despite it being
something
barack obama did and then as the evening
wore on
not only did donald trump's face
continue to melt not only was he more
and more visibly sweaty gripping the
podium almost like he needed to in order
to stay upright
he became increasingly unable to speak
tried to say we are going to end our
reliance
instead set our resilience and then
abandon the entire sentence
i change and we will end our resilience
for bad things we will go right after
china
we will not rely on them one bit donald
trump
still unable to say kasim solimani's
name
one terrorist by far kasim
solomini and the context of bringing up
solamani is actually interesting because
a number of speakers did this
within seconds of each other other
speakers
and donald trump throughout the week
bragged about how
donald trump kept us out of and
got us out of wars and bragged about
bombing iran
at the same time it's orwellian
doublespeak
you like one thing you focus on that
that doesn't sound so good
well trump said the opposite 30 seconds
later you can focus on that instead it's
a sort of something for everybody type
of approach
donald trump misreading proudly as
profoundly
my fellow americans tonight with a heart
full of gratitude and boundless optimism
i profoundly accept this nomination
for president of the united states
and then by this point donald trump
simply sleepwalking and sleep talking
finally done 70 plus minutes in
his face has completely melted and this
is
the wrap-up and what you'll notice is
it's been monotone for so long
you you couldn't tell until the last
second that it was finally the wrap-up
there were multiple moments where it
seemed like maybe the rap was starting
but just droning on and on and on people
on their phones people sleeping
people maybe passing coronavirus back
and forth
this was the the final wrap up after
seven seventy minutes of sleep talking
and on november third
we will make america
safer we will make america stronger
we will make america prouder
and we will make america greater than
ever before
i am very very proud to be
the nominee of the republican party
i love you all god bless you and god
bless america thank you very much
so a bunch of different thoughts here
first of all
this was really fascistic and
authoritarian in a lot of different ways
the way that he is couching the
opposition as something which of course
they are not
socialist marxists um donald trump
continually not making sense making the
case that
the united states is really chaotic
right now there's crime everywhere it's
crazy
so you should re-elect trump well
trump's president right now
and of course the argument would be well
the chaos is in democrat-run cities
i'm going to deal with that later on in
today's program and if you elect trump
he will stop the chaos well
he's been president for four years and
he hasn't stopped it at least as far as
he's concerned
so that narrative makes no sense
simultaneously the narrative of
berating china and democrats and who
knows who else
for the virus but doing it at an event
with 1500 people
sitting six inches away from each other
with no masks
not having been tested for coronavirus
that's also
completely illogical uh and then tom
nichols had a very
interesting commentary on the broader
optics of the speech nichols tweeted
something like
this is his same rally speech that trump
gave
but with a dramatic background the
visual component
of the white house and tom nichols said
this is why you're not supposed to use
the white house as a political prop
because
in a different venue this is much more
obviously
trump's same rally stump speech ranting
but with the background of the white
house
it lends it more credibility than it
deserves and it's exactly why you
shouldn't be giving speeches like this
at the white house i thought that was a
very good point
last thing the insistence on marxists
and socialists that the entire
convention but in particular trump
yesterday claimed to be running against
and claim
represent joe biden's views if you know
anything about joe biden you know joe
biden is no marxist or even close to it
but what that is increasingly code for
is
that the platform of joe biden and the
democratic party right now
is one that recognizes that working
people
who live paycheck to paycheck are
disgusted with the murderous failure of
this administration on coronavirus
because that's what it's been
and are responsible the trump
administration
for the dramatically worse than it
needed to be economic situation
as a result so when they talk about
marxists and socialists
those are fear-mongering terms to take
attention away from the fact that this
administration has failed the very
population that they claimed
were going to be doing great which is
just average working class people
inequality up chaos from the standpoint
of
reacting to protests over police
brutality
an embarrassing laughing stock of a
coronavirus response where countries
have stopped laughing at us now they
pity us now they're scared
and donald trump wrapping it all
together fear-mongering about marxists
and socialists while using the white
house as a political prop
to make people sit there for more than
70 minutes
of his monotone droning in one of the
most authoritarian ways that we've seen
him do it
this is really scary stuff and
unfortunately if you've been watching
this week you know
it could work to get him re-elected
let me know what you think i'm on
twitter at deepakman
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors susman and han
sussman and han has everything you need
when it comes to face masks and other
protective gear for kovid 19 and they're
giving my audience 20
off sussman and han is the company that
i personally have been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell
that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor i have tried
tons of different masks this year
and i still have not found a mask that's
more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cotton
that feels great on your skin
it has convenient adjustable straps it
features a disposable five layer
particle filter made of activated carbon
they also have disposable cloth masks
which are really comfortable as well as
other gear
like face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers
and all of their prices are very
reasonable i also love sussman and han
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions they're
a great company
you can get there by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is underneath this video
and you can save
20 percent off of everything in their
store
when you use the coupon code david